halloween le 11e de la série remporte un
succès monstre en deux semaines le film
a amassé 175 millions de dollars aux
michel mondiale comment expliquer que
les films d'horreur font toujours un
malheur
aucune chimie une question de timing de
dosage sébastien diaz réalisateur de la
série web erreurs 404 et encyclopédie
vivante de films d'épouvanté adore le
genre de des conventions d'être un peu
nono les personnages suivants vont faire
quelque chose c'est le compte mais
voyons pourquoi qui retourne la retourne
pas là
ils horaires rémy couture l' artiste
maquilleur en a fait son gagne pain
hors-oeuvre pas nécessairement aussi
dire décapitation les intestins partout
plaçant on peut exploiter l'horreur sous
une forme beaucoup plus intelligente
beaucoup réfléchi aps la naissance du
film d'horreur remonte aux années 20
mais les années 70 ont été fastes
l'exorcisme les griffes de la nuit
arrête j'entends quelque chose massacre
à la tronçonneuse
car oui et les dents de la main le
québec à d'abord été un lieu de
production de films d'horreur canadiens
et étrangers venus 110 on s'épaule mais
s'est tourné à peu près 50 films
d'horreur au québec
j'ai eu une taille qui explosait
l'universite concordia
aujourd'hui le film de peur réalisés au
québec se porte bien
les affamés et sortis grands gagnants du
gala québec cinéma 2018
notre cinéma de genre s'exporte très
bien depuis quelques années et plus vu
que beaucoup de gros films québécois
qu'on encensait à qui on donne 4 5
étoiles
les haqqani est un bon exemple l'être
humain aime se faire peur on aime les
sensations fortes ce qui se passe le
film d'horreur n'est donc pas près de
mourir ici julie jasmin boudreau radio
canada montréal
[Applaudissements]